oi entrei logo depois da tempestade na
floresta não é qualquer coisa
é uma honra estar aqui boa tarde para
falar do eu aceito ofereço tanto
presencialmente quanto virtualmente para
tantas pessoas
mas o que é ou aceita ofereço é um grupo
de internet seja no facebook que tem
como foco o acolhimento muito
empoderamento e fortalecimento de
mulheres de várias realidades
falando assim parece uma sem graceza que
dói mas eu juro que a descrição que não
faz jus à grandeza dessa coisa que eu
pare e não falo pare por acaso é porque
esse grupo nasceu assim do âmago de
dentro de um isabella que estava
desorganizada desbussolado desnorteada
diz qualquer coisa que vocês queiram pra
falar de uma pessoa que tenha se perdido
do seu próprio caminho pessoal eu tinha
passado por um processo muito longo e
fui me perdendo m desencontrando e só
percebi quão profundo tinha sido esse
processo quando decide arrumar minha
casa literalmente tinha coisas
empilhadas até o teto papel móvel velho
coisa que vai fazer um acúmulo e aí eu
já estava me reorganizar andando e foi
deixando a a a organização de um dia
para o outro foi deixando pra lá adianta
aquele momento de me re arrumar onde eu
morava até que descobri que estava
grávida de uma menina
então a necessidade de abrir espaço
físico e emocional para aquela criança
que estava vindo e eu ainda nem conhecia
que já amava tanto se fez urgente
aí eu fui é barriga crescendo cheio de
hormônio abrir uma caixa começar a
arrumar as coisas
eu chorava aí eu ia pegar uma pilha de
papel tentava organizar trava e num
cômodo bloqueava eu me sentia sua
fracassada de estar naquela situação de
ter me permitido chegar até ali
que mulher já se sentiu assim
sobrecarregada sozinha
a sensação de fracasso foi muito muito
ruim mas já naquela época eu tinha em
mente que eu merecia ajuda
mesmo quando eu falava e foi punida
dessa idéia que eu fui pra frente do
facebook abriu em box para 33 mulheres e
disse olha nessa situação abrir meu
coração fala da gravidez foi como me
sentia e pedir ajuda para elas pra fazer
uma faxina uma faxina me ajudar a
retomar minha casa e abre espaço para a
filha que ia chegar e elas vieram juntas
em dupla passar a tarde inteira ficaram
só uma hora juntando a power com tampa
conta qual é
e foi ali reorganizando a casa as coisas
indo para um lugar a gente falando muito
sobre o feminino e todas absolutamente
todas as que tiveram na minha casa
falaram sobre as dificuldades de pedir
ajuda logo ela que estavam ali comigo
isso na minha cabeça foi em maio do ano
passado em julho para a barriga já na
boca os hormônios borbulhando eu olhei
para minha casa e vi tudo organizado que
pensando como aquela experiência merecia
ser compartilhada com outras mulheres
eu conversei com uma amiga ana fernanda
falei pra ela dá ideia ela topou a gente
criou eu aceito ofereço saímos pra
cuidar das nossas coisas que quando
voltei já tinha centenas de mulheres no
outro dia milhares em menos de uma
semana tinha cinco mil participantes
trocando interagindo longamente mulheres
de várias partes não apenas salvador mas
do brasil e de outros lugares do mundo
a prova de que eu me conectei com uma
necessidade que já está em todo mundo da
gente ser mais generoso e lidar com mais
simpatia tanto com a gente
enquanto com o outro mas como é que
funciona o grupo é simples você vai lá e
colocam eu aceito e pode ser ajuda para
fazer uma faxina tempo um texto um
objeto para casa não importa desde que
esteja conectado com suas reais
necessidades e seus reais desejos também
hoje não se coloca eu ofereço e o céu é
o limite também pode ser um livro uma
informação ajudar alguém desde que seja
dentro das suas reais
possibilidades porque não é o lugar de
ninguém sacrificar é o lugar da gente se
acolher por isso que eu aceito vem antes
do ofereça como as mulheres se colocam
ali de uma maneira tão ampla precisa de
regras para funcionar não é só quem só
tem quatro apenas mulheres sitrans não é
permitida a troca de nenhuma natureza
permuta dinheiro nada não podem
divulgações externas de divulgação de
nenhuma natureza e os conteúdos não
devem ser compartilhados de fora é para
um lugar pra gente falar da gente e as
mulheres falam falam interagem e se
movimentam plenamente naquele grupo e
por isso a gente precisa de uma
moderação muito firme e muito atenta
para a gente conseguir lidar com essas
intimidades sem passar por cima assim na
homogeneização e pra isso ficam aqui
meus agradecimentos pelos moderadores
que fazem tudo funcionar mil que abby
thaís barros marcelo marcone liliane
dias cibele aguiar julia maia e laís
machado que já teve com a gente
além de ana fernanda essas mulheres
estão ali o tempo todo lidando com as
coisas começando em box e propondo de
uma forma quase pedagógica mesmo esse
novo estar no mundo porque a internet
faz um monte de sentimentos levantar que
às vezes não são os mais nobres né
os reitores trouxe aquela agressividade
ea gente ali vai levando para um caminho
de respeito de escuta e delicadeza que é
difícil as elas pedem que as regras
sejam mais rígidas mas eu acredito
plenamente que a gente está um novo
exercício de compartilhar uma
coletividade mas amorosa e as mulheres
trazem exemplos incríveis e acreditam
que aquilo ali funciona como a mulher
que o outro lado do atlântico quando
veio visitar a mãe dela aqui na bahia
percebeu que a senhora estava muito
sozinha com o seu exemplo e ela pediu eu
aceito a alguém que vai fazer companhia
para a minha mãe e ela recebeu uma onda
de amor tão grande que ela precisa fazer
uma tabela para organizar as visitas que
a mãe dela receber uma que vai fazer um
bolo a outra foi assistir
filme a outra pessoa bater papo ou senão
uma outra que colocou eu aceito alguém
para fazer uma feira e prepara um jantar
pra mim porque eu tô voltando do rio de
janeiro depois do divórcio com os meus
filhos e queria oferecer uma refeição
digna pra alguém foi e ela jantou em
família com essa mulher que ela não
conhecia para recomeçar a vida aqui uma
outra que ofereceu ajuda para as recém
paridas mais sol que precisavam de ajuda
ali na rotina com o bebê
eu me emociono todos os dias como
emocionando agora porque são dezenas que
familiares de exemplos de pessoas que
acreditam nessa nova possibilidade está
no mundo
eu poderia ser encher sete dias e sete
noites aqui com exemplos de mulheres que
sequer se conheceriam se o grupo não
existisse mas ele existe não só existe
como tem grupos filha e grupos irmãs
espalhados por pernambuco maranhão
interior da bahia
bélgica irlanda argentina demonstrando
que essa percepção das mulheres se
juntaram para se ajudarem mutuamente
está por aí ea gente chega num ponto
muito importante porque apenas mulheres
a resposta é simples que eu como mulher
me sentia mais habilitada mais à vontade
para compartilhar isso com pessoas que
têm demandas mais ou menos próximas a
mim mas nada impede que os homens tenham
grupo tipo eu aceitei oferece também eu
acho que essa diferente mas isso é o que
menos importa
e se os homens se abrir sem que saiba a
possibilidade de lidar e de uma forma
mais generosa com suas próprias
fragilidades e com as fragilidades dos
outros
eles já iam fazer parte dessa onda de
repensar o coletivo de forma mais gentil
mais afetuoso e essa onda vai crescendo
crescendo
eu acho que ela pode tomar o mundo por
isso que eu estou aqui hoje porque eu
acho que essa idéia era ser
compartilhada pode parecer pretende
de rose impossível mas se vocês é sempre
aquela isabella la de um ano atrás
grávida
amparado chorando na frente do
computador que ela estaria aqui hoje
falando sobre o eu aceitei ofereço ela
diria que era uma utopia mas ao que
parece uma utopia do real do concreto
uma utopia do impossível que está
acontecendo agora graças a várias
pessoas conectadas
porque é como eu sempre digo lá no grupo
juntas somos infinitas
ficamos bem
[Aplausos]